is there a certain type of person who's
more likely to become addicted or more
likely to have multiple addictions
across multiple domains yeah so our
innate vulnerability to addiction varies
and some people are definitely more
vulnerable than others I'm about 50 of
the risk of getting addicted is
biological or inherited so there are
studies showing that if you have a
biological parent or grandparent with
addiction you are at increased risk
compared to the general population of
becoming addicted yourself even if
raised outside of that substance using
home so there are really interesting
adoption studies showing that one people
with a biological parent with addiction
are raised in a non-substance using home
they are increased risk of developing an
addiction themselves do you know if
someone who has an alcoholic father is
more likely to be a gaming addicted son
that's very interesting I don't think we
have data on that what we speculate
though is that this is a general
vulnerability to addiction rather than a
specific you know vulnerability to only
one substance and we know that because
many times when people will get in
recovery from one addiction that they'll
go on to become addicted to something
else